ربما تكون قد سمعت عن الاضطراب العاطفي الموسمي ،
وهو نوع من الاكتئاب
المرتبط بالتغيرات في
الفصول وهو أكثر من مجرد بلوز
شتوي.يبدأ بشكل عام في الخريف ويمكن أن
يستمر حتى الربيع ، وقد يكون أحد الأسباب الرئيسية
هو نقص ضوء الشمس عندما
الأيام التي تصبح أقصر وهذا يقلل من
مستويات السيروتونين لدينا مما يؤثر على مزاجنا
سبب آخر قد يكون أن أولئك الذين
يعانون من هذا الاضطراب ينتجون
الكثير من الميلاتونين مما يجعلنا نعسان
وخمول وتشمل أعراض نقص الطاقة
وزيادة الحاجة إلى النوم
والانسحاب من الأنشطة الاجتماعية
أقل.  الشائع هو الاكتئاب الصيفي الذي
يحدث في أواخر الربيع إذا كنت تعتقد
أن هذا قد يكون ، فلا داعي للقلق ، فهناك
طرق لمكافحته ، الخروج لامتصاص
المزيد من تمارين ضوء الشمس كل يوم ، وهذا أمر
أساسي في رفع مزاجك وتغيير نظامك
الغذائي والمزيد من فيتامين د.  قد تساعدك أيضًا في
إعادة صياغة تركيزك بدلاً من الخوف
من الموسم ، فكر في الأمر من حيث
الإيجابيات ، وأخيراً انظر إلى أحد المحترفين
لا يمكنك دائمًا القيام بذلك بمفردنا ، لذلك لا
تتردد في الحصول على المشورة الطبية من
أجل Health minutes ، أنا ميريديث
وود